on the mound for the rangers tonight a
little bit of a difficult start against
the white sox which drove those numbers
up a little bit but overall had a a
pretty stunning year nice start to this
season for his new team in the rangers
he shoots this one on the ground right
past first base so fletcher is on to
start things off tonight
and that one scalded up the middle for a
base hit
trout
is on in his first hit bat tonight
bases are loaded an immediate chance at
redemption
for anthony rendon who left five
stranded yesterday including four in
scoring position three and one to rendon
he shoots that into right field
it's going to bring in at least one a
second run being waved around throw on
walsh is not in time it's two nothing
angels
two run bases loaded single by anthony
rendon only one of his six sliders
thrown for a strike tonight and that
one's lined into left
wall scores they're going to wave rendon
around throw to the plate is not in time
four nothing angels
oh two
in the pitch he struck him out swinging
another change i think
and that ends the inning but the angels
get four runs on four singles
alex cobb on the mound tonight for the
angels era over six he has struggled so
far the strikeout rate
is up but when players put the ball in
play against him they're hitting 4
36 lots of line drives off of them
in the air right field toward the corner
and that one will bounce off the wall
for extra bases solo to second base and
he has a one out double
next third double of the year
one out base runner in scoring position
here's the next 2-2 to gallows snuck the
fastball inside and got him sinker
struck him out looking low tied for the
rbi lead at 21
hitting 267.
ground ball that one out into the grass
right field that's a long throw not in
time and coming around third to the
plate solax scores all the way from
second base
it's an infield hit for low but heads up
base running by nick solak and the
rangers are on the board two balls and
two strikes to garcia
got him to chase one a little bit higher
outside struck him out and that is how
the inning will end stassi just
activated today off the injured list
and he strikes out on three pitches to
start the second inning back-to-back
strikeouts for dane dunning three and
two and the pitch to fletcher struck him
out swinging well fletcher the guy who's
so tough to strike out one-two pitch
strike three called and that was
beautifully placed by dunning well he
strikes out the side he used the change
up and he used the fastball twice
the rangers are trailing four to one but
jonah heim is about to come to the plate
as the tying run and the pitch and
there's a ground ball to first that'll
score a run
here's the first baseman walsh flipping
to the pitcher cobb for the out
time with an rbi the angel's lead is
four to two
kinder philetha scores and hope winds up
at third
ball and that one sneaks through
holt scores calhoun
delivers a big hit
and the rangers make it a one-run game
[Applause]
and gallo pops it up
rendon hoping it stays playable for him
and it does
a big out
to end a two-run rally for the rangers
tour gone for max stassie two-strike
pitch on the way swinging a miss
breaking ball gets max stassi for the
final out at a one two three top half of
the fourth three and a half complete
rangers continuing to trail the angels
here four to three his career pitch
count high is 41 and that's not to say
that he can't exceed that
holt serves a fly ball into schedler's
field and right
and they're too gone
next deliveries is bounced on the right
side and this is gobbled up by fletcher
from the outfield area with the shift on
and he will throw out heim and that was
a super quick inning there for rodriguez
as he throws only eight pitches and sets
them down
cleanly bouncer by ohtani solac right
there
two up two down
the last angel base runner was a walsh
who singled lead off the third
and was wiped out in a fly ball double
play
trout swings bounds one to third a big
high hop for holtz his throw is true big
stretch by low it's a one two three
inning and we're going to the bottom of
the fifth still angel's four rangers
three it's amazing he's had plate
coverage down and in
out and away
how about just down the middle
next delivery gallows swings to that one
chops the ball on the first base side
it's fielded there by walsh he'll solo
to the bag and that will wrap up the
inning
so another clean inning for
chris rodriguez he throws just 10
pitches he's retired the last
eight that he's faced four runs in five
innings leaves his era at 397.
swinging a miss sallard strikes out
walsh and that is out number one
still two balls and two strikes to
iglesias batting with a man on and two
away
that sprayed into right a base hit
a fine plate appearance by jose iglesias
and the halos have runners aboard with
two gone here in the sixth from the high
set to the plate
swing and a miss he struck him out
put him on a cutter it appeared and the
sides retired no runs a hit two left he
was with houston last year and then
acquired at the end of july by the
angels
gets his ball hard out to left field
dull right there to make a knee-high
grab david dahl got a good jump on it
nice running grab coming in
swinging a miss otani misses the
fastball up and in and strikes out as
allard retires the side in order seventh
inning stretch time in arlington it's
still angels four rangers three tying
one is on base in the eighth inning so
now joey gallo
gallo swings and sends a fly ball now to
right deep in right field schedler is
under he'll make the catch on that one
another put out for schedler that's five
put outs for the angels right fielder
tonight and the rangers had that time
run 90 feet away one two
got him again yeah go right back in
there
and that is how the inning will end they
end up leaving the tying run at third a
pair of runners left stranded micelle
iglesias three for five and save
opportunities the next one too
comebacker for iglesias a perfect ninth
and for the first time this year the
angels have claimed a rubber match they
take two out of three from the rangers